this video is made possible by north VPN
start protecting your internet
experience today with 77% off a three
year plan by using the code biographic
s-- nord VPN comm forward slash paya
graphics North Korea is a country
shrouded in mystery they do not allow
their citizens to leave and they cannot
receive information from the outside
world the very few people who are
allowed inside are under strict
supervision from the perspective of the
United States and the rest of the West
we see Kim jong-un as a communist leader
who is threatening nuclear war and
violating human rights we also see him
as someone who's had a hand in a number
of assassinations of his enemies for
some people that's all they need to know
to form an opinion and they imagine that
he's an evil dictator or on par with
that of Hitler but the truth about this
man
it's far more complicated
[Music]
before we get into the details of kim
jeong-hoon
it's important to understand a little
bit of history about North Korea during
World War two Japan was occupying career
and the country fell into a state of
extreme poverty they became independent
again in 1945 but the country was now a
rock bottom it was extremely difficult
to raise the economy out of the
depression especially since they were
years behind the Western world in terms
of manufacturing and transportation this
desperate time made some citizens open
to the ideas of communism where the
government is responsible for providing
food shelter and employment to its
citizens the USSR it was eager to help
so Russia provided weapons to North
Korea and it split off from the South in
their leader was a man called kim ill
sung in the beginning thanks for
actually going quite well
Kim Olson kept his promises he improved
agriculture and no one was hungry
anymore
he brought industrialism to the country
which gave the citizens jobs they built
up the capital city of Pyongyang and the
country was progressing very quickly for
years North Korea was actually ahead of
South Korea in progress people loved Kim
Elson in fact they loved him so much
they called him the supreme leader and
began making up legends that he was in
God with supernatural abilities but in
1950 the Korean War began and the USSR
and China teamed up with North Korea in
their attempt to take over the South the
United States fought on the side of
democracy and they helped South Korea
win back their territory American
soldiers are still stationed at the
border to this very day even though the
war was nearly 70 years ago in the North
Korean version of history America
attacked first and they were just
defending themselves this triggered
years of anti-american propaganda and a
ban on all american-made products and
the feeling it was definitely mutual the
United Nations created trade embargoes
against North Korea and refused to work
with any communist nation after the
collapse of the USSR in 1991 North Korea
it ran out of money and triggered a
widespread famine where citizens were
once again starving people struggled to
survive this was no longer the utopia
that Ken Olsen had envisioned and his
son Kim Jong
l was doing very little to fix anything
during his reign if anything he
exploited his power to the fullest
extent and did things that were truly
evil which only made North Korea's
reputation even worse Kim jong-il had
several children with multiple
mistresses at least three sons and two
daughters are known to the public Kim
jong-un was his third son born in 1983
Switzerland was one of the few neutral
countries that were willing to work with
North Korean diplomats therefore Kim
jong-il sent his children to boarding
school their bond was given the alias of
pact on he got to experience a normal
childhood living in an apartment with a
family who worked at the Swiss Embassy
he was given lessons on how to speak
German but he had to enter a class of
students who were two years younger than
him in order to catch up on the reading
level at first he struggled but he was
eventually able to make good friends
with the other children his teachers say
that he enjoyed playing Gameboy him that
his favorite sport was Baskerville he
was an average students who enjoyed gym
class far more than academic subjects he
wore different night track suits every
single day to school at home he loved
watching the NBA and American action
movies his mother was one of Kim Jong
Il's mistresses an opera singer named ko
young-hee she would fly back and forth
from North Korea on a private jet in
order to visit him sometimes staying for
several weeks at a time he was able to
visit several countries in Europe and
Japan and spend most of his young life
learning about the world outside of
North Korea when he was 17 years old he
was taking high school classes and
preparing for graduation one day
Paco didn't come to class and everyone
assumed that he was out sick but days
turned into weeks and he never came back
he was ordered to leave so suddenly
that's he never even got to say goodbye
to his friends he had begun taking
college classes in North Korea he was
never allowed to tell anyone about the
secrets of the outside world since the
entire nation was still living like it
was frozen in some sort of time capsule
from the 1960s his older brother Kim
jong-nam was originally supposed to
become the new leader of North Korea the
second son schorl is described as being
very effeminate and not appropriate for
a fierce leader Ahn was third in line
for secessions so growing up he never
really expected to take on that
responsibility
however the eldest
ma'am he got himself into a lot of
trouble in 2001 and was caught using
fake passports while trying to take his
family to Tokyo Disneyland's and it got
all over the news his carelessness made
members of the North Korean elite loose
trust in his abilities for the next two
years now would openly criticized the
way his father was running the country
in 2003 he was exiled from North Korea
and 20 year-old hoon was told that his
older brother was gone he would need to
become the next supreme leader when Kim
jong-il had his first stroke and was 25
years old his advisors knew that it was
time to begin teaching him how to become
the new leader however when his father
died in 2011 on had only had about a
year of political training at this point
but it was too late at 26 years old he
became the dictator of North Korea once
he was revealed to the nation as their
new supreme leader people were skeptical
about his young age but they also loved
him right away he was very friendly and
smiled mannered and he reminded a lot of
people of his beloved grandfather Kim
il-sung the superstitious Korean people
began ARIMA verben was actually a
reincarnation of his grandfather who had
to come back from the dead in order to
bring North Korea back to its former
glory
[Music]
there are very few living people outside
of North Korea who know Kim jong-un well
enough to be able to testify for his
character Kenji Fujimoto is a chef from
Japan who was hired by Kim jong-il to
cook his meals and they became good
friends after unreturned home from
studying abroad but yumoto was one of
the very few people who could talk to
you openly about the outside world he
marveled at the fact that foreign
grocery stores were always filled with
food but in North Korea they were always
empty who knew that there was something
deeply wrong with this country and he
wanted to make it better he confided in
Fujimoto that when he became the new
leader he planned to model North Korea's
economy after China whose wealth boomed
from their production and worldwide
distribution it's thousand and twelve
when he gave this first speech as the
new leader Kim jong-un declared that
this would be a new North Korea and all
the struggles were the hindlimb when he
came to power children they were still
dying of malnutrition and his first
mission was to make sure that his people
had enough to eat he spoke about his
immense respect for the loyalty of his
people and how they deserved so much
better he said our people should never
have to tighten their belts again from
day one Kim jong-un had made an effort
to be the polar opposite of his father
Kim jong-il never made a single public
speech during the course of his reign he
kept his citizens out of the loop and
completely avoided interacting with them
his father and his friends in the elite
class enjoyed a life of luxury any help
from charities from the outside world
went to feeding the ridge while babies
continue to die of starvation every
single day I'm Jang Gyung
had to undo decades of damage done by
his father it would take time but he
kept his word and set out new economic
and agricultural reforms that brought
more food to the people within a year or
two people were healthy again and was a
young possibly naive man with big hopes
and big dreams he truly did want to use
this position of power to fix this
country but he would soon find out that
even in the position of supreme leader
some problems are far too complicated
for a single person to fix
before Kim jong-un came to power
generals were national heroes and they
were all a part of an elite class in
North Korea a lot of the power in
government was with these military
leaders many people don't realize that
North Koreans call their country the
DPRK which stands for the Democratic
People's Republic of Korea but the
People's Republic was clearly lacking
the funding and power that it needed one
of Kim Jong Un's first executive
decisions was to remove all of the power
from the military and give some of it
back to the people and their
representatives his uncle Jang
song-thaek was a decorated general so
this executive order stripped away much
of his political power before Kim Jong
Il died there was some speculation that
Jang song-thaek would become the new
leader of the country since son was
still so young for the first year of
UN's reign Jang song-thaek offered his
nephew some guidance in how to run the
government but it was clear that he was
just trying to be a puppet master this
only lasted for about a year in 2013 Kim
jong-un ordered the execution of his
uncle he was shot by a firing squad in
the past whenever there was a sudden
death of a member of the elite everyone
knew that it was an execution but the
government would explain it away by
saying it was a car accident or a heart
attack or something like that Kim
jong-un shocked the public by saying
that yes he was the one who had had his
uncle killed because his uncle was
trying to overthrow him and take the
position of supreme leader for himself
in North Korea if someone commits a
serious crime there are only really
three options send them to a prison camp
kill them or ex Alvin considering how
much power Jang song-thaek had in the
North Korean military killing him was
really the only option Kim jong-un also
kills many of the men who were helping
his uncle plan the coup for the other
military leaders running the government
Kim jong-un forced them into retirement
and replaced them with people that he
knew he could trust it was later
revealed in the international press that
his uncle was a pedophile and he had an
arrangement with Kim Jong Il when it was
still alive they targeted extremely
young girls who were auditioned to be a
part of some artistic role they need to
become his playthings
he had these young girls bathe his naked
body daily they
while we're not trying to promote murder
killing Jang song-thaek with firing
squad was letting him off easy compared
to what inmates would have done to him
in the US prison system however the
Western media latched onto this story
saying he went on a killing spree
this was also very shocking for North
Korean citizens to hear because they are
a culture that deeply respect their
elders while North Korea is still very
sheltered from the outside world Kim
Jong has actually made a lot of effort
to slowly incorporate modern life into
the DPRK he has invited in groups from
around the world to entertain and teach
people in things that they'd never seen
before like a group called surf North
Korea however these are special
privileges that are reserved for in
elite class it has also allowed North
Koreans access to smartphones computers
and HD televisions students are also
learning computer programming in
university however they cannot get
access to the world wide web and there's
only one TV channel and that's used for
state propaganda also those phones can
only make calls locally and all of this
is still only affordable for people in
the upper class Kim Jong young began
sending his country's current and future
leaders to schools in Singapore Vietnam
Canada and Hong Kong in order to receive
a proper education in economics and
politics he hopes that they will return
with a better understanding on how to
change the North Korean government and
help transition their economy into a
free market many people get access to
DVDs and flash drives smuggled in from
China with South Korean TV shows and
movies it is now common for citizens who
own TVs and computers to see what the
outside world is truly like even though
they are not allowed to leave all made
an unlikely friendship with the
professional basketball player Dennis
Rodman in a 2018 interview with CNN
Rodman explained that he wanted to give
Kim jong-un a present for his birthday
by flying over an American basketball
team to North Korea no one in their
country had ever seen an NBA game before
despite the difficulty getting into the
country Rodman was able to pull it off
Kim Jong and told him this is the first
time someone has ever kept their word to
me he went on to explain that people
usually spout false promises
trying to make peace with his country
and that makes it nearly impossible to
trust any Outsiders for the people who
have defected into South Korea they say
that the transition comes as a shock
there are so many more lights cars and
people than they are used to actress
yeonmi park says that she is always
studying very hard to catch up to her
peers by learning how to read and write
the Korean language and catch up to
everything there is to know about the
outside world we will never be able to
read kim jong-un's minds to see his
long-term goals if the truth of the
outside world was brought to these
people who have been living in isolated
and depressed life for so many years
would be a revolt and kim jong hoon
would lose his power if he wants to open
North Korea up to the rest of the world
it's not something that can be done
overnight remember that these people are
essentially stuck in a time capsule at
this point exposing them to the outside
world all at once would be incredibly
overwhelming and it may lead to
bloodshed we don't know if he is more
concerned with keeping people oppressed
to maintain this power if he knows that
the process of globalization in North
Korea will take time what we can do is
speculate
when he was alive Oona's father helped
himself to a harem of actresses and
singers and he arranged for his three
sons to have the ability to sleep with
any woman that they wanted but according
to Kenji Fujimoto the teenaged who
simply wasn't interested in sleeping
around he was very protective of his
younger sister and showed a lot of
respect towards women in general he
preferred to read books watch movies and
played basketball over partying and
going on dates
Fujimoto was so shocked by the boy's
disinterest in the harem that he often
wondered if the boy was actually gay one
day though and made a comments that
confirms to Fujimoto that he did in fact
like girls just as much as any other
teenage boy he just wanted to fall in
love Kim Jong Young is married to a
woman named Reese all June she was a
singer in her younger years but after
marrying Kim jong-un she began pursuing
a college degree in science and
completed a PhD the details about their
relationship were kept secret and their
marriage was only announced in 2012
after he became the new leader of North
Korea however some say that they had
already been married for years before
then as first lady resoled who enjoys
organizing events for her husband and
she is often seen accompanying him in
public while there seems totally normal
to the outside world kim jeong-hoon is
actually the first North Korean leader
who allowed his wife to be seen in
public he also brings along his sister
arms and one of his father's former
consorts with him to events because they
are part of his inner circle of advisers
well they never know the intimate
details of his marriage their body
language shows that they are very loving
with one another according to Dennis
Rodman he met one of their daughters a
little girl named Joo a many have
speculated that he has multiple children
but they are never shown in the public
eye to protect their anonymity they are
reportedly receiving a private education
abroad just like their father did
instead of relying on the male heir to
take over his throne kim jeong-hoon has
been paying for the training of his
younger sister kim yo-jong so that she
can become the new supreme leader of the
country if anything should happen to him
she is usually present during very
important meetings with national leaders
[Music]
barley is better than his father in just
about every way kim jeong-hoon
is far from being the perfect leader
North Korean citizens are still not
allowed to come and go from the country
as they please as a communist nation
people are not allowed to choose their
own career they do not have freedom of
speech or religion and the press is a
never-ending propaganda machine one of
the main criticisms he receives is for
the harsh treatments of prisoners in the
gulags and the concentration camps
prisoners are being used for uranium
mining and their bodies have been
riddled with radiation considering that
he wants to keep up with his nuclear
arsenal at uranium mining has become a
necessary evil then of course there's
the fact that Kim jong-un has made
multiple threats of nuclear war against
the United States this is an incredibly
frightening thing to think about
and it has any Americans on edge however
when you interview South Koreans not
many people are worried despite the fact
that they live right next door but they
believe that Kim jong-un's nuclear
threats are the only thing that the
country has for leverage in order to
prevent a more powerful nation from
invading remember there are thousands of
American troops at the border and with
all the other major powers in the world
owning nuclear weapons this is just a
way for them to become on level with
mutually assured destruction meaning
that no presidents in their right mind
would attack a country who has nuclear
weapons at their disposal because it
would mean both countries would be
obliterated
even though military training is a
requirement for every citizen in North
Korea Kim jong-un never received any but
the North Korean propaganda machine has
built up this myth that he was sent away
to receive some of the best military
training in the world so he runs
military drills to keep up this illusion
he was given the equivalent ranking of a
three-star general none of the young
soldiers have ever been to war and the
military leaders from the Korean War
they're all gone further north Korea has
outdated weapons that were given to them
by the Soviet Union decades ago and
while they are dangerous there is no way
they could ever win a war if they took
on South Korea a man named Robert Carlin
is a CIA negotiator with North Korea and
he summed up the grand show of nuclear
power perfectly one thing every North
Korean leader has understood and Kim
jong-un does too is the
if they lower their guard they will be
treated by the major powers as the used
furniture of history they will simply be
discarded walked over ignored otherwise
why pay any attention to them so they
have to make sure people care about them
in 2018 kim jong young met with the
president of south korea moon jaein and
the President of the United States
Donald Trump in order to bring their
countries to a place of peace where
progress can soon be made we can only
hope that there will be a solution to
this incredibly complicated situation
without ever going to war so Kim jong-un
North Korea scary stuff and you know
what else is scary Packers and not just
of the governmental variety
I might sort of be joking it chances are
your data isn't really interesting to
North Korea but hey every day we hear
about in the news how there's some sort
of latest hack or data breach of some
variety not good and governmental
surveillance is certainly something that
goes on but good news you can protect
yourself with a VPN and that's where
Nord VPN comes in evidence sitting in a
cafe with some open Wi-Fi network and
wanted to check your internet banking
well don't even think about it without
Nord VPN well let's say you were a
foreign person living in an oppressive
dictatorship with very restricted
internet and you wanted to watch a fun
YouTube video like this one very matter
I know well Nord VPN will sort you out
there too or maybe more likely you just
want to watch your local content from
your own country while abroad well Nord
VPN can also do that Nord VPN is also
super fast so watching video is a breeze
no lag whatsoever so if you've ever used
VPNs and thought they were slow well
that's certainly not the case with
naught you can also use it on all your
devices very very easily Android Chrome
Windows Linux and on six different
devices at the same time all with one
account so that makes it incredibly
affordable also there are no logs kept
unlike some companies based in the EU or
the United States Nord VPN based in
Panama they don't keep blogs at all it's
kind of like the opposite of North Korea
great for your privacy indeed they are
the only VPN to get a perfect score from
PC Mag Nord VPN is offering live viewers
77 percent off three year plan
just go to Nord VPN dot-com bio graphics
or click the link in the description to
sign up and start protecting yourself
today that's Nord VPN complex bi o gr AP
h ICS and use the code biographic some
check out to get started today so I
really hope you enjoyed that video as
always please do hit that thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe and
I will see you in the next one
[Music]